The Walking Dead returned for its season
7 premiere and we're still in shock with
Hooten Deegan beat the death with his
baseball bat Lucille however aside from
the death viewers learned that the world
is a bit larger with the addition of
Ezekiel played by Carrey Peyton
I am King Ezekiel but who is this weird
new character we're diving into the
world of The Walking Dead comic book
series to let you know five things you
need to know about Ezekiel number five
first and foremost Ezekiel's the king of
the community known as the kingdom this
group lives in a high school and has
buses and sheetmetal surrounding the
property
Ezekiel's made himself the leader of
these lands he acts like a king all the
time speaking in an off-putting dialect
that doesn't fit in the current world
number four while The Walking Dead is
known for its villains with
larger-than-life personalities Ezekiel
was one of the first heroes to come
along and steal the spotlight because of
his past community theater work Ezekiel
took on the role of a powerful yet
happy-go-lucky King at first he seems a
bit mentally unbalanced compared to the
rest of the survivors in the world
however readers later learned there's a
method to his madness number three
before Ezekiel was an eccentric ruler of
his own Kingdom he was a zookeeper he
worked there for years and cared for
animals under his watch he even returned
to his old work after the outbreak to
help one animal out in particular number
two the craziest thing about Ezekiel
isn't that he's a king or sometimes
speaks in old English is that he goes
everywhere with his pet tiger Shiva when
the world first started going to hell
Ezekiel returned to his place of work
and found Shiva alone and famished
since he raised Shiva's and she was a
cub he felt the duty and obligation to
nurse her back to health the words
spread that there was a man with a tiger
roaming around which added to the legend
of the character number one the most
important thing about Ezekiel is that he
makes a powerful ally to Rick and a town
of Alexandria the kingdom has the power
and the numbers to take negan and the
Savior's down but Ezekiel isn't easily
persuaded in the comics the kingdom
becomes a key factor in the war against
vegan and it seems like that'll be a big
part of this season's storyline
for more TV movies and Walking Dead keep
it here to GameSpot universe turn these
people in I mean the ones that are left